intentemos restar 9.57 menos 8.09 dale
pausa al vídeo y prueba a hacerlo por tu
cuenta antes de que lo hagamos juntos
escribamos la operación pero hagámoslo
de manera vertical es decir alineando
los puntos decimales 9.57 menos 8.09
ahora si estamos listos para calcular la
diferencia para empezar queremos restar
9 centésimas de 7 centésimas aquí no
tenemos suficientes centésimas
veamos por de agrupar estos números para
que la cifra de arriba sea mayor
aquí tenemos 5 décimas a las cuales le
queremos restar 0 décimas así es que
tenemos suficientes décimas aquí como
para reagrupar esto de la siguiente
manera estas cinco décimas vamos a
transformarlas en cuatro y la otra
décima equivale a diez centésimas
entonces esto va a ser diecisiete
centésimas y ahora si vamos en la resta
17 menos 9 es 8 centésimas
4 - 0 es 4 el punto decimal
9 - 8 es 1
1.48 es la respuesta